Obama
look at that
look at that look at that look at that
that is
smarter than you what who thinks he's
smarter than you what you think he's
smarter than you
know
look at that
look at that look at that Pac-Man's a
loser Pac-Man's a loser Pac-Man's a
loser at that man's a loser
look at that Alex Jones is lying to you
that might come as a shot
[Music]
this is
n't it
[Music]
a corporate takeover censorship
demanching arrest tyranny
corporate takeover censorship debanking
arrest tyranny
[Music]
tyranny look at
look at that look at that look at that
Pac-Man's a loser Pac-Man's a loser
Pac-Man's a loser Pac-Man's a loser he's
a description he's a disgrace
these are the scratch he's a disgrace
look at that look at that I'm worried
about my espresso machine I'm not
that can be your headline
headline it's not a joke I'm worried
about my lathe
up there like
um
just exploded I'm sorry about getting
rid of the machine felt him down and
turned him into prison bars pillows I'm
not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers the
lawyers are lawyers the lawyers are
lawyers get rid of the machine I'm
trying for getting rid of the machines
just pillows who did this attack who did
this Cyber attack so you have you know
the good Geeks and they patch it up and
they fix it and they put up better
protection virus protection but here's
what my attorney said she said
[Music]
um
do you frequently go to Hardee's is that
a common place you go okay that's pretty
funny
that could be your headline the machine
I said I would have passed through on
the way to find a ride through it's
really incredible The Branding around
Madison no you're not getting my phone I
said arrest me I've done nothing wrong
he said no we're not gonna arrest you I
said
[Music]
getting rid of the machine
thank you
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is Trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample Trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
[Music]
dumps
big massive dumps
[Music]
dumps dumps
big massive dumps dumps dumps
big massive dumps
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is just
dumps
amounts of water where the water rushes
[Music]
what is going on here what is go what is
going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here what is the what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
costing the election
what is going on here dumps
jump jumps
mangoes
I love mangoes too
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now costs
[Music]
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
that's it eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
bring my mango
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mangoes
[Applause]
[Music]
well welcome everybody into the new
studio it is the new look David Pacman
show Studio very spacious in here I
absolutely love it it's the new mustache
I cleaned up for everybody today uh had
a major major workout at the gym and it
would not have been appropriate to do
this stream without a shower and so it
is all happening I shaved and it is it
is just all happening in an incredible
way and it is so great to be here folks
is this anyone's First State of the
Union Address let me know in the chat if
this is the first one for you
uh watching it I guess I would say
um and let me know if this is your first
time using the internet that would also
be an interesting thing I do want to put
up on the scoreboard we are already at
10 actually 11 new subscribers which is
great I think we're gonna have a
fantastic night we are going to be here
for the State of the Union starting at
the top of the hour as you can see on
your screen uh Joe Biden has not yet
left the White House it is a relatively
short drive from the White House over to
the capital it is uh tradition I guess
we would say for those who are not I
should sit in the middle let's see okay
I want to make sure I'm Centered for
everybody a relatively short trip and it
is part of the tradition that the
president will head over from the White
House to the Capitol and uh be greeted
by certain Congressional leaders and
it's all going to be happening tonight
and it is such a great thing now I want
to put right up front I am not
prejudging you know things start to leak
about what to expect and I don't want to
pre-judge tonight
until we hear the speech but it appears
as though Joe Biden is going to be
making a number of policy proposals
tonight's State of the Union at this
early stage of the night maybe maybe one
of the most policy heavy just thick with
policy wide even as well
um and if that is the case if they stuff
this State of the Union Address with
policy up the wazoo
uh I would actually really like that and
it will be a very very interesting thing
to review in detail on tomorrow's
podcast which I hope everybody is
listening to on a regular basis we
actually had you know YouTube is in the
toilet 10 to 15 times but last month was
the best month ever for our podcast
approaching uh quite frankly approaching
a million downloads a month on the audio
only podcast which for for such a humble
podcast as ours is really really great a
lot of people asking about what's going
on with the Shaving so I have good news
on the shaving and bad news on the
shaving and on such an important night
I'm not going to spend the whole day I
know that the mustache is very
distracting there's actually a guy
behind AOC here who I believe has an
even more distracting mustache than me
look at see that guy right there
if you think my mustache is distracting
imagine having to keep the camera steady
with that guy in the background as you
can see but needless to say
um I am I really don't know what the
right razor is for me you know 20 years
ago I was using a Mach 3 and everybody
came to me people on the show and said
David for a man of culture such as
yourself you really shouldn't be using a
Mach 3 you need to be using a safety
razor there's all these different things
I've tried everything quite frankly I
got a beautiful German safety razor with
um uh Japanese blades and I cut myself
up the Wazoo and people say oh well you
need to learn the technique maybe the
the technique just isn't I maybe I just
don't know it's not learnable for me I
don't know most recently I tried the one
blade which is sort of like a cross
between a Mach 3 and like a single
safety razor I I don't know what I can
tell you is working for me
is I got a Boar's hair boar bristle
brush and some beautiful beautiful
shaving cream that's all working really
really well
um but on the blades I just don't know
and I'll be honest I'm about ready to go
back to the Mach 3. so if people want to
send me suggestions I'm I get so the the
one blade does not give me a close shave
and it just hurts like hell it really
hurts like hell so if people want to
email like an appropriate suggestion uh
info davidpackman.com the brush is
critical I'm brushing I'm doing big
circles and then I'm you know doing all
this stuff it feels it feels beneath me
to go back to the Mach 3. It Feels So
wasteful but
um I may not have a choice I may not
have a choice and I may have to do it
all right so let's get that out of the
way uh let's do the following this is
what's on the table for today
um our initial goal is a hundred website
members and twitch subscribers if we get
to 250 I will stick around for the
rebuttal speech from Sarah Huckabee
Sanders the new governor of Arkansas
passing a very powerful anti-crt Bill
CRT not taught in schools but just in
case you can never be too careful if we
get to 250 I will stick around and if we
get to 500 I will fill in the mustache
with some die and do a couple of shows
with it and I will look absurd but I
will do it okay if we get to 500 we're
filling in the mustache uh and it's
going to be crazy I would even be
willing to fill it in some different
color than than my natural hair color so
that's that's on the table but not blue
it has to be and it has to be a
naturally occurring color uh so I'm not
gonna do blue
but
um I'm willing to do that if we get to a
billion then I will uh I will retire
tonight okay let's look at a few super
chats kuya Isaac says David will you
please look into the camera and say
Mickey sucks this is a gameplay with a
friend of mine and this could get me a
lot of points uh no I'm not gonna do
that NH Barracks have you tried Henson
razor with discount code majority I
should try that I really should that
might be the way to get the uh maybe
that'll get me the best shave Rusty
Shackleford dumping in a 50 Super Chat
says love the stash it's very Pedro
Pascal keep it growing free Rusty green
man I paid monetary tribute to the man
now lift the unnecessary mute
Bradbury says David I would recommend
Harry's Razors much better than Gillette
products and Steven says Sir With Tears
of laughter in my eyes you're zoomed in
background on the live stream says Man
Show
new studio looks great though oh that is
interesting yeah look at that it's The
Man Show
women welcome non-binary people welcome
everybody everybody here is welcome
um I do want to thank a couple other
really really great people
um Billy Carpenter and pilot pilot dog
dirt nap Jen here multi-beast all of
these really really fantastic people
dumping in an additional 12
subscriptions putting us at 23. and a
big thank you to Martin Fillion for
gifting a subscription on my website
folks free subscriptions are still
available all you have to do is go to
davidpackman.com free membership
fill it out and you'll be next in line
for a free membership so like Martin
just donated one so now someone gets a
free membership if you can't afford one
or you don't want to go to
davidpackman.com free membership fill it
in
and it'll be a very very exciting thing
okay I have a whole bunch of things to
get to with everybody
um I let's just go through a couple
other super chats Bay photo says Welcome
Back Sir love the new set George Santos
was an excellent guest host last week
may I recommend Harry's Razors PS will
someone shout obscenities at Joe Biden
tonight if yes then who I believe okay
so let me give you a couple of
predictions tonight
um I believe the balloon will be
discussed tonight I believe someone on
the Republican side will yell out at Joe
Biden
without a doubt without a doubt and I
believe that Joe Biden will be very
policy heavy this evening those are my
predictions uh they may not be much but
they are indeed my predictions okay
Haley says tomorrow George Santos will
say he gave a great state of the union
speech best of the age absolutely
cardiothoracic surgeon George Santos
tomorrow will be delivering his own
response
Daniel says David it's nug free Rusty
free Rusty all right
very powerful thanks to meaty legs and
bionic bill for the twitch subscriptions
very much appreciate that always always
always appreciated
um
you know there
people are getting one dollar
memberships does anybody know how people
are getting one dollar memberships I
don't even know how that's possible on
the website does anybody have any idea
two people just signed up for a dollar
and I don't even know I didn't even know
that was possible
Sean and Peyton how did you get dollar
memberships
that's really strange
thanks to Prue and cubamoo BS button as
well
no no these are this is on my website
it's not about being in a different
country I I genuinely don't get that
please email me and tell me how you
subscribed for a dollar I have no idea
how you did that
and now Tim did it
what on Earth
this is genuinely bizarre
I think so it must be monthly
how are people doing this I genuinely
don't know
like what coupon code could I use
please no more Trump like what does that
do
something's funky here
210 no so that's not it
huh
anyway if one if somebody who did that
can email me in all seriousness I don't
know how people are doing that all right
let's get into some other stuff let's
look at a couple of clips from my
appearance with Patrick Bet David now I
do genuinely really appreciate
really appreciate all of the kind
comments that I received about my
appearance uh on the Patrick Bet David
show I also think that there are some
things I did
that I could have been better prepared
for I really do so
um let's look at a couple of Clips here
let me see which ones they are uh okay
let's look at a couple of these we
should have some kind of minimum Level
Health Care system for everybody and it
would it would actually be cheaper than
what we have what we have includes
people that go to the emergency room as
primary care which is insanely expensive
sometimes they don't pay their bills and
that leads to everybody who does have
health insurance is just absorbing that
cost true it would just be cheaper if we
provided everybody some basic level of
care there are states that have done it
I think that's just a basic thing
um and secondly I would like to
socialize some aspect of paid
um uh family leave
parental and and maternal do you guys
hear that PSY he just made really
expensive it's economically stimulated
stimulative in the sense that when other
countries have done it they find that
productivity ends up being higher when
pair parents returned to work and you
know it's been been widely studied we
should have some kind all right so
that's not bad uh people are telling me
the website is down I don't think it's
down for everybody
because
um there are 22 people right now uh
working on getting memberships but let
me see what's going on
the website's been funky lately I'm not
gonna lie no the website pulled right up
for me and uh Kirsten Hartman as well as
Martin Fillion had no no trouble signing
up I'm just going to give the website
the old reboot just in case just in case
let's hit that reboot server thing that
should hopefully clear out the pipes a
little bit I still don't know how people
are signing up for a dollar I I'm losing
control of my own website guys I'm not
gonna lie
the free membership link you mentioned
didn't work
davidpackman.com free membership
uh
oh the website's just rebooting but it
works fine okay let's continue let's
look at the next clip from this uh here
we go would you vote for a Republican
sure yeah
I mean if if I have you ever voted for a
Republican president
no I mean
yeah but see now this is one of those
cases where like he responds with he
just changes the topic it goes from
would I to have I different things
different things hold on a second but
you're 40 years old you're you're 1994
I'm 38 please 84 38 years old 30 years
still you've had plenty of Elections
let's back up for a second
there's two questions would I and have I
I've only voted in a few presidential
election you've got plenty of chances
well but who would I voted for I was
going to vote for George W bush in 2004.
no right absolutely not so uh let's see
there was that let's see what else we've
got
it's not only if covet didn't happen
Trump probably would have gotten
reelected I think if when kovitz started
instead of trump saying we have 15 cases
soon going to be zero do flu vaccines
work on covid what about bleach
injections all that stuff if instead of
that Trump said hey you know what we're
the United States we're going to deal
with this better than anybody else we're
making Maga masks and by the way 50
cents on every dollar will go you know
his his normal fundraising scams right
do the scams but do the Maga masks and
if he said we're going to be absolutely
the best on this thing he wins we saw it
in New Zealand we saw it in other places
it was a missed opportunity now I think
it was just a miscalculation in the
sense that somewhere Trump probably
thought it was really going to go away
now that's one of those things not only
if because of his audience I'm trying to
be a little bit more charitable like I
don't think Trump had a clue one way or
the other I think Trump was just a
so I tried to be like oh you know maybe
Trump genuinely thought it was going to
go away but it didn't and be like Marge
originally more charitable
um let's see what else do we have why am
I not a socialist why are you not a
socialist I think that the market is a
fine way to direct resources in the vast
majority of areas whether it's sneakers
or automobiles or cell phones I think
that that's absolutely a fine way to
direct resources I see it as an
authoritarian imposition for a
government to come to a business owner
like you or like me and say you must
socialize the ownership of this company
right and I I'm against that I don't see
any reason for that I don't see a legal
basis and I don't see a moral basis for
it what I am okay with as a capitalist
right so and I know I saw your
conversation with my friend Kyle
Kolinski and it seemed like you guys
were talking past each other a little
bit on social democracy versus socialism
or whatever
I consider myself a Social Democrat sort
of in the mold of Denmark Sweden etc
those are capitalist countries that have
decided to socialize a couple more
things than we've socialized in the
United States right that's really the
difference and and it's capitalism it's
a form of capitalism yeah why are you
not it was a pretty wild wild time
that's for damn sure my favorite clip
from the entire thing was this one did
during Trump Russia attack Ukraine no
what happened with Palestine and Israel
what happened now at that moment I'm
like
I genuinely do what what happened I
don't know what he's talking about I
actually don't know what he's talking
about there I'll Stand in Israel
what happened yeah what happened they
came together after 20 some years what
what are you talking about when you say
what are you talking about
[Laughter]
that's absolutely my favorite moment
from the entire interview
where it's like he realizes he also
doesn't know what he's talking about so
he turns to the other guy Israel and
Palestine came together this is
absolutely my favorite moment did during
Trump Russia attack Ukraine
no what happened with Palestine and
Israel
what happened yeah what happened they
came together after 20 some years what
what are you talking about when you said
what are you talking about
did during Trump Russia oh God what a
moment what a moment let me see if
there's anything we're gonna pop the
entire things already out already
um
there's a bunch of these here this one
got
this one got 5.5 million views oh look
at that why do you think they didn't
like or respect Trump let's see what
you're going to say with that why do you
think tell me the guy's a joke he is
yeah okay tell us why and bike man
Biden's not a joke we can talk about
Bible because Biden's like the goat no
no Trump's the joke no no no no no he's
a joke but I think it's important to say
are we talking about Trump or are we
talking about Biden no no you talk about
identify talk about them one at a time
stay on Trump stay on Trump when he say
he's a joke tell us why you think he's a
joke
um
promises made that were not kept that he
told us he was going to achieve for us
let's look at some of them I'm going to
get rid of Obamacare and replace it with
his word a beautiful replacement where
everyone will have care and it's going
to be affordable right okay
just flat out didn't happen the one
proposal that Republicans made would
have led to 24 to 32 million people
losing health care I consider that a
failure I don't think Obamacare is
perfect but it's better than the think
Trump think Trump said he was going to
bring us that was that was just a
failure two build a wall across the
entire U.S Mexico border which Mexico is
going to pay for
it's not even worth having a conver I
mean just a joke of course of course
completely didn't happen solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict no progress
made in fact to be honest and this is
you know if we want to delve into that
moving the embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem got us further from that
because it's seen as a sort of um a
taunting measure if you understand the
internal politics of what's what's going
on there
um was going I think this is when when
Patrick started getting a little bit
triggered where he didn't like this you
know the made some space travel promises
I mean we could I can't think of
promises he made that he did keep other
than
um I guess the the he was going to do
tax reform and he did tax reform so as a
policy matter a complete and total
failure I do think maybe the first step
act on Criminal Justice Reform did some
good things I'm sort of glad to give him
credit on that
um but so you know on policy failure and
then you know on red rhetoric we could
spend three hours just looking at quotes
why do you think that anyway I encourage
you to check out the entire thing it was
a pretty pretty interesting experience
for sure
um and uh we'll be publishing the entire
thing with like a bigger commentary that
I'm gonna do I believe tomorrow or in
the next couple of days over the next
short period of time that's for sure I
also appeared while I was down in so the
Patrick Bet David interview was in
Florida in a specific part of that state
Florida
I also appeared with Anthony pompliano
that interview was in Florida it's a
different part of of the state that I
believe they are going to be publishing
this week and we will have
um
we'll have clips and more more
information about that it's already that
interview is already on pbd's YouTube
and we'll have it on our YouTube
tomorrow okay everybody thank you very
very much I want to say thank you to
some great people Dylan Folger as well
as Lisa Rader Taylor Ashley and Giovanni
Castro thank you for signing up on my
website folks here's the deal we have an
initial goal of a hundred website
members and twitch subscribers today and
boy do we need them after the YouTube
Fiasco if we get to 100 we will go for
250. at 250 I will stick around and
stream the Republican rebuttal from
Sarah Huckabee Sanders if we make it to
250 we will go for 500. and then if we
get to 500 I will die the mustache a
color to be decided upon by the audience
we are in the new studio absolutely LR
fan asks if I saw repugnant Marjorie
Taylor green carrying a white balloon
around the capitol I did it was pathetic
um we have members of Congress entering
we will of course go to live audio in
about 15 minutes when Joe Biden arrives
there as senator Amy Klobuchar Dick
Durbin behind her you see Senator
Charles Schumer here in the sharp blue
suit with the red glasses they also have
a guy named Mitch McConnell there as you
can see looking like the center of the
party there is lying Republican
Congressman George Anthony quitara De
volder Santos speaking to Willard Mitt
Romney Willard Mitt Romney making nice
with George Santos who who the hell
knows what he's going to say today uh
Republican senator from South Carolina
Tim Scott at the bottom right of your
screen
all sorts of folks coming in you see
Lauren bobert with the glasses in the
upper right of the screen by Matt Gates
as you can see the Matt Gates head
almost completely obscuring like an
eclipse Lauren bobert but certainly they
are both there that I can assure you
um
Senator Menendez there in the glasses
behind Tim Scott filing in
uh Joe manchin here at the front shaking
hands
Mitch McConnell just really looking like
the life of the party as all of us have
known him to be
um and as you can see also Joe Biden's
motorcade starting to make its way over
to the Capitol I do expect a policy
heavy speech from Joe Biden we are
expecting a number of new proposals that
is Speaker of the House Kevin McCarthy
who won after what was it 15 votes 20
votes something like that there is
formerly Democratic senator Kirsten
Cinema
uh she's the one in the yellow dress I
know it's hard to spot her there a very
subtle and sober outfit on uh on on such
a day a day is this there is Senator Joe
manchin who uh whose suits are often
much much much too big for him that's
also a trump move there is um Rick Scott
who just shook hands with
uh lying sen Congressman George Santos
Charles Schumer the Senate majority
leader of course
uh thanks to Jason sickmeyer for signing
up on my website for a membership you
are number 43 today also thanks to Josh
Myron who signed up on my website your
new member number 44 and a huge thank
you to Ocean Nova Breezy deeper shades
of house and Bowflex man for the twitch
Prime subscriptions it's so great to be
back and to see everybody we still have
about 20 minutes before too much gets
going uh there is Congressman Hakeem
Jeffries speaking to I don't know who
was that Joni Ernst I couldn't tell from
the back we see Massachusetts Senator
Elizabeth Warren in the blue
speaking to I don't know who that was
actually
I don't know who that was I have a
recommendation for folks I don't know
how many of you are aware of this but um
Brian Cranston just a fantastic actor
from Breaking Bad and the dentist on
Seinfeld he spoke with Bill Maher and
Bill Maher tried to pull some of this
anti-woke stuff and I really like the
way Cranston handled it let's just
listen to a couple of minutes I
recommend watching this in full no I I
just think we need to live in the year
we're living in and acknowledging
progress
is not saying uh the past isn't horrible
or that we're done and there's no more
work to be done it's just being
realistic about where we are today and
where we are today is nothing like the
times you're describing
uh as bad as they were so so what so
you're you I mean this is I think a
problem with a lot of the left they are
they seem to be obsessed on the past the
past is important it's not the only
thing
most places do teach it there are places
there are also there are there are
places that go too far on either side
can we agree with that but I bet both
sides ISM most places in America I mean
again this is 2023 the people who are
doing the teaching are of a generation
that is not mostly interested in
suppressing the past or being racist I
mean I disagree with that well then you
don't watch a lot of the videos that
they themselves post
they themselves teachers and educators
trust me they're they're Brian just
trust Bill Maher super aware of race if
anything it is injected too much into
everything
but you sound like you're more in the uh
Hollywood woke camp and I I'm not that's
fine it doesn't mean we have to like
it's it's a humanistic camp
I want I want did did you did you know
when you were a child did you know that
that segregation was all through again
when I was a child was the 60s yeah this
is 2023. when you keep going back to
like yeah
it is of course you know what racism is
always going to be present in in not
just white people but in all people it
to a certain degree you can't you total
red herring completely
um
sanctify human nature it's just what it
is it's tainted uh we try to extra tape
it as extirpated as much as we possibly
can but we can't certainly it's a great
thing that we've passed most of the laws
that you would need I mean
discrimination is illegal has been for a
very long time obviously it'll always be
fought in the courts and so forth but
though but it's like such a simplistic
misunderstanding of the way the world
actually works you know we made it
illegal guys I mean come on it's been
illegal for a long time oh a pretty good
point huh as opposed to these errors
you're talking about when it wasn't even
the law
Jim Crow yes before the Civil Rights Act
yes but that's a long time ago so and we
seem to think that the the country in
2023 is populated by
seething racists who are who are unaware
of our past and and the obligation we
have to do better I
I do agree that there are people who who
want to move forward without looking at
the past and when you move forward
without looking at the past and course
correcting you're in trouble because it
can happen again okay we do both can't
we look can't we be cognizant of the
past yes and move forward and
acknowledge the president what's great
is this isn't even what Brian Cranston
does and he really just does very well
here let me ask you a question yeah when
you look at this guy's hat make America
great again what do you think about that
sweetheart nobody has made more fun of
Donald Trump than I I know so you can't
get me on like I like Donald Trump I
don't like that okay I'm not saying I
get your point I've said it myself yes
make it all right anyway you know we're
short on time tonight but I I really
like what Brian Cranston um did here I
thought it was really very very good uh
and I encourage people to check it out
thanks to Tyler Jackson for gifting two
subscriptions and Haley Quinn for
signing up on my website this puts us at
52.52 as a reminder the State of the
Union Address will start in about 12
minutes Joe Biden is making his way over
these are just preliminaries they're
pretty meaningless we we never really
listen uh to them it's just Kevin
McCarthy trying to use language to
communicate and it's not it's not
particularly pretty I will tell you that
um the military leaders are here we are
still awaiting the Supreme Court members
of the Supreme Court we will see if they
all attend or they do not after the
State of the Union Address Sarah
Huckabee Sanders will be giving the
Republican response I believe from her
state of Arkansas I sort of want to just
like go to bed but if we get to 250
members and twitch subscribers I will
stay I will stay and stream that as well
uh so there could be a pretty big pretty
big night ahead of us uh let's just
briefly wait where did I want to go next
did I want to go here
uh oh yeah here is Senator Kennedy not
of the democratic Kennedys okay this is
Senator Kennedy he's a republican here's
his sort of preview of tonight's speech
listen to this Washington you have to
watch what people do not what they say
um in Washington
what what you do is what you believe and
everything else is just cottage cheese
after two years we know what President
Biden believes because we we know what
he's done
um
bigger government higher taxes more
spending more debt more hey in all
seriousness
has Joe Biden raised taxes like I know
sometimes taxes are raised but I really
don't know what they're talking about
like I follow this stuff relatively
closely
maybe it happened the week I was away
did Joe what taxes did Joe Biden raise
I'm just I know tonight he's going to
propose a Billionaire's tax one of the
most Progressive proposals we will see
from a sitting president in history if
indeed he proposes that tonight but I'm
not aware of taxes being raised
people aren't sure yeah I I don't know
guys yeah
an open border a weaker military
um criminals of the good guys
um a a drag queen for every school
library whether the parents want that or
not
now those aren't words
um that's President Biden's record yeah
anyway these people are living in a
complete and total fantasy world that's
that's really the uh the unfortunate
thing
uh unfortunate for us and them I guess I
would say Danny Mickel with a beautiful
Super Chat says a state of the union
speech isn't complete without a David
pakman commentary and Analysis this is
easily one of my favorite channels for
politics keep it up Sir Danny thank you
thank you and remember if you are
watching on YouTube for absolutely no
money whatsoever you can make sure that
you're subscribed to the YouTube channel
very very very easy very very very easy
and I hope that everybody has liked the
stream even though I see that you have
not and I would I would love for you to
hit that subscribe button because it is
a very very big deal we actually had a
best month in in years last month with
over 40 000 new subscribers quite a
scene
um Amy Klobuchar and other folks are are
making their way through here and it's
all happening pretty powerfully Dustin
says David sir it's a little outdated
did you get word of me infiltrating the
RNC party with your show logo on my kick
drum I did and it I was away and we
didn't get to it but it was very funny
and uh it's a delightful delightful
thing let me see if I can find it
if we have time here
I don't have it in a place that I can
easily access it unfortunately
unfortunately Heather Burns just signed
up at joinpakman.com and his new member
number 53 very much appreciate that
today's coupon code is please no more
Trump
please no more Trump as you type it in
you actually have to say it that way
let's listen to maybe like one voicemail
one voicemail
um just because we're all here together
in the new studio okay
you know what really pisses me off more
than Marianna thinking that she can just
pass off her
uh really horrible bizarre
uh schizophrenic
whatever you call it to get all right so
one voicemail and we've done it and now
we can move on I think I don't know that
we need to necessarily do more of that
uh thanks Eric for the Super Chat I very
much uh very much appreciate that and
thanks to DJ White Rabbit for the twitch
Prime subscription okay
um what do we have coming up on the show
this week that's a great question let me
see what we do have coming up uh
tomorrow I will be interviewing George I
hope I'm pronouncing this correctly it
does he pronounce it mon biat does
anybody know I don't know what the
accepted Western pronunciation is
um
wait Wednesday we don't usually do an
interview on Wednesday that's actually
odd
anyway that'll be tomorrow okay that'll
be tomorrow if you're just joining us we
are moments away from Joe Biden's second
State of the Union Address it is
expected to be very proposal heavy I do
believe that at least one Republican
will yell something out I don't know if
it'll be George Anthony Katara devolder
Santos or maybe Lauren bobert or
Marjorie Taylor green but I do think it
is very likely someone yells out it is
uh almost almost commonplace now uh cry
for attention from these folks
um we are now seeing
let's see who's coming in now
uh man I don't know who these guys are
anybody know who these guys are
now we lost the live feed let's just
refresh it
oh now it's the Supreme Court
it's a little weird to cheer for the
Supreme Court right it's sort of like
great job in a completely non-partisan
way evaluating how the Law relates to
the facts of cases
I mean it's just sort of like it's it's
a it's almost strange really to to clap
uh in that scenario thanks to Michael
Devore for the twitch Prime subscription
You're Number 54 today
um moments away from Joe Biden he
probably has arrived at the Capitol but
is just waiting before
um making an entrance and that will be
very soon
okay a lot of people asking am I
covering the Huckabee Sanders response I
will cover the Huckabee Sanders response
if we get to 250 members and twitch
subscribers otherwise I'm going to bed
because
um I have a seven month old baby and
sleeping is good okay so that's the way
it's that's the way it's going to be
um
there's Elena Kagan John Roberts
a lot happening here huh a lot happening
George Santos is here George Santos is
here I know a lot of people are
it's more of I think a morbid curiosity
than it is anything else quite frankly
uh uh there is the second gentleman
Douglas emhoff thanks to Rhino dactyl
and N3 for the twitch Prime
subscriptions there is the first lady Dr
Jill Biden Republicans that's getting a
little louder Republicans will be quick
to remind you she is not a medical
doctor
and that is of course true she never
pretended to be a medical doctor
thanks blueberry babe for gifting a
subscription I appreciate that
Rusty Shackleford says via uh Super Chat
Rusty has been free do you think Brett
Kavanaugh is hiding a few beers under
his robes I hear he likes beer I read he
was going to be boofing uh in secret
uh during this event there was was that
Bono from you too
Brian says via Super Chat at least one
Republican Will shout something out my
favorite pacmanism so far today
Joe Biden's cabinet is now entering
a very very powerful cabinet folks come
on in I see people who are just kind of
like sticking their head into the stream
and they're not sure whether they should
stay or not everybody's welcome here if
you troll or attack people you'll get
banned but everybody is welcome here and
it is such a great thing to see you
um
we're we're this it's starting in a
second everybody relax it's starting in
a moment
a lot of handshaking and very powerful
this is what we call glad handing I
think
yeah no people are getting upset that uh
they're not sure if this is the right
place just hang out everybody's welcome
okay
everybody's welcome
I am not sure how long the speech is
expected to be
um State of the Union addresses
historically very big range of duration
very big range there is Secretary of
Transportation Pete boot Edge entering
the
um the chamber
I want to say thanks to you're not going
to get me with this coal Cole just
signed up at joinpakman.com tried using
a fake name that was going to be vulgar
but I didn't fall for it I didn't fall
for it folks much to your dismay
on average these speeches roughly go an
hour and a half yeah I mean if you just
have to say very very roughly speaking
let's see a duration of
State of the Union addresses
the shortest one I can find
is
let's see
oh these used to be pretty damn short
Richard Nixon once gave a a 28-minute
State of the Union Address that is I
would love that I would love that
historically they have gone longer
Joe Biden's two addresses
the first one wasn't really the State of
the Union ran uh 61 and 65 minutes
Trump's went as long as 82 minutes Trump
does struggle to read and that probably
was in part responsible for it
um
Barack Obama had won as short as 51
minutes and as long as
69. Obama uh anyway you get the idea
um it would almost certainly be over by
uh uh 10 30 Eastern I think is where
we're going to put it there's Pete Budaj
Ed shaking hands with Willard Mitt
Romney
who's this guy
did not recognize him that's for damn
sure
uh great to be yes great to be back I
appreciate all of the kind words from
everybody Giovanni says what if you
messed up and brought you bought
yourself another subscription instead of
gifting it uh that's a tough situation
not too too much I can do about that
unfortunately
I wish I could do more I really do
very very much do thanks to Sacred heels
TV for the twitch Prime subscription
very much appreciate that
Cinema is off the rails yeah folks
talking about my mustache not really the
subject today we are on the verge of Joe
Biden introducing some very uh
significant policy some of it quite
Progressive from what I've read and we
are not going to make this a referendum
on my mustache but as I did say I will
die the mustache I will fill it in if we
get to 500 website members and twitch
subscribers I think it is reasonably
unlikely
so I probably won't won't have to do
that is my mustache on a war footing it
is it is absolutely Bryce asks did I
give Sam seder his panels back I did
yeah we are now in the extraordinarily
roomy new David packman show Studios I
cleaned up for everybody I shaved I
trimmed the mustache because I respect
you so much and it is such an important
evening and we are indeed in the new
studio
uh and I love it I have to tell you I
think it's a fantastic fantastic studio
thanks to Jason sickmeyer and Patrick
Boland for gifting to subscriptions if
you want to claim a free subscription
just go to davidpackman.com free
membership very very easy to do and Joe
Biden any moment how many subscribers to
shave half the mustache okay listen how
about this if we get to 500 we will do a
poll where I will either shave half the
mustache and do a show with half a
mustache or fill it in
or maybe both would be interesting
listen if we get to 500 I'm willing to
do anything people want with the
mustache other than one particular thing
which I'm sure everybody knows what it
would be there is something that would
be totally inappropriate to do with the
mustache we don't even have to mention
it and it's not even on the table it's
just I'm not gonna there's that one
thing I wouldn't do Nelson says it's not
George Santos there's a doppelganger
It's gotta be
David says wondering would you have shot
down the Chinese balloon uh I would have
scooped it up like with Newt Gingrich
thinks we have these huge balloon pooper
scoopers I would have scooped it up with
a pooper scooper I think that that would
have made a lot more sense
thanks to moguyu and aerys for the
twitch Prime subscriptions pushing us to
63.
any moment President Joseph R Biden Jr
will be entering to start officially his
second State of the Union Address but
sort of like the third Jake says
mustaches are brave
Firestar says great mustache I like that
Nobel Laureate George Santos
has just subscribed on Twitch
here we go
welcome everybody Mr Speaker
for those joining us from overseas this
is President Joe Biden here entering uh
he is the president of the United States
he did something remarkable in November
of 2020 he received more votes in enough
states to defeat Donald Trump now I know
many of you have heard that there are
lunatics in our country who don't
believe that that happened let me be
here to assure you
Joe Biden won into November of 2020 it
is an uncontroversial claim to make and
here he is as president of the United
States
[Applause]
we are keeping a very close eye on
George Anthony kitara devolder Santos
will there be any acknowledgment
whatsoever from Joe Biden let's hope not
Lauren bobert what will she do I do
expect some Republican to yell out some
horrible thing at some point during this
speech without a doubt it seems to be
almost a requirement will it be dark
Brandon presenting his speech today or
not we will soon see a billionaire tax
expected to be proposed by President Joe
Biden a number of other legislative
priorities for the second half of his
first term and it is actually being
considered almost like a setup speech to
outline what his 2024 re-election
campaign could be like could be like if
he were indeed to announce which he is
expected to which he is expected to uh
you alien has just signed up via twitch
Prime I really appreciate that also
thanks to Giovanni Castro who just
gifted a subscription on my website
there is someone out there who will very
very much appreciate that uh the if
you've not seen one of these speeches
before it is filled with Pomp and
Circumstance there is a lot of clapping
as the president enters and and says hi
to everybody uh generally speaking
everybody claps at this point in time
both Republicans and Democrats the
president will then be reintroduced up
on the uh uh Deus for lack of a better
term at that point again everybody will
cheer Republicans and Democrats as is
the convention it's really there's a
number of these please clap moments
throughout the speech you will see
partisan clapping where often
Republicans Or democrats will clap but
not the other party it will be a
typically a perfect partisan split uh
and this is just the the way it it sort
of goes
um it always is this way let's see if we
can squeeze in
um a few more Super chats as they come
in Sean says David I saw your twin at Mr
Olympia his name is Chris Bumstead
Google it let's see Chris Bumstead
uh oh my God that guy looks nothing like
me uh Haley says go teaser for evil
twins Hail to the Chief
says set looks great but I'd like to see
you touch the plant love your show keep
up the great work oh I don't touch the
plant
it's very very dangerous to do that I
would never do that
um thanks for all you do
suddenly the Biden IRS death Quad Squad
storms the State of the Union ordered to
gun down every congressman who voted to
condemn socialism oh boy yeah that's
that's getting pretty pretty out there
salami is the latest twitch Prime
subscriber I very much appreciate that
folks uh we are probably looking at
about 65 to 70 minutes as far as a
speech goes here
once it starts and this is why we're
talking about 10 30. because it will
take a little while before it starts uh
Sarah Huckabee Sanders will give the
response if we get to 250 website
members before the end of Biden's speech
I will stick around for the rebuttal if
people don't want that perfectly fine
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
members of Congress I have the high
privilege and distinct honor to present
to you the president of the United
States
okay
speaker
thank you you can smile it's okay
what is happening thank you thank you
thank you
thank you please
cut it short huh Madam vice president
our first lady and second gentleman
good to see you guys up there
members of Congress
by the way chief justice I may need a
court order she gets to go to the
game tomorrow next week I have to stay
home
got to work something out here
leaders of our military chief justice
associate Justice and retired Justice
Supreme Court and to you my fellow
Americans
you know I start tonight by
congratulating 118th Congress the new
Speaker of the House Kevin McCarthy
wow treating people with respect what a
moment
people who deserve no respect by the way
speaker I don't want to ruin your
reputation but I look forward to working
with you
and I want to congratulate the new
leader of the House Democrats the first
African-American minority leader in
history Hakeem Jeffries
former guest on the David packman show
Hakeem Jeffries by the way
he won in spite of the fact I campaigned
for him
congratulations the longest serving
leader in the history of the United
States Senate Mitch McConnell where are
you Mitch
congratulations to Chuck Schumer another
uh you know another term is was Senate
minority leader uh you know I think you
uh this time you have a slightly bigger
majority Mr leader you're the majority
leader
about that much bigger
well I tell you what I want to give
special recognition to someone who I
think is going to be considered the
greatest speaker in the history of the
House of Representative Nancy Pelosi
wow
folks the story of America is a story of
progress and resilience
of always moving forward of never ever
giving up
is a story unique among all nations
we're the only country that has emerged
from every crisis we've ever entered
stronger than we got into it look folks
that's what we're doing again
two years ago the economy was Reeling I
stand here tonight after we've created
with the help of many people in this
room
12 million new jobs more jobs created in
two years than any president's created
in four years because of you all because
of the American people
boo jobs boo jobs says McCarthy
and two years ago
[Applause]
but had shut down our businesses were
closed our schools were robbed of so
much and today covert no longer controls
Our Lives and two years ago democracy
faces greatest threat to the Civil War
and today though bruised our democracy
remains unbowed and Unbroken
understand that he's talking about
bruised by Trump's presence for four
years
[Applause]
story story of progress and resilience
when world leaders asked me to Define
America they do believe it or not
because I can Define it in one word and
I mean this possibilities
we don't think anything is beyond our
capacity everything is a possibility
you know we're often told that Democrats
and Republicans can't work together but
over the past two years we've proved the
cynics and naysayers wrong
yes we disagreed plenty and yes there
were times when Democrats went alone
but time and again Democrats and
Republicans came together came together
to defend us stronger and safer Europe
came together to pass one in the one in
the generation once in a generation
infrastructure law Building Bridges
connecting our nation and our people we
came together to pass the most
significant law ever helping victims
expose the toxic burn pits and in fact
foreign
there's Beau bear
in fact
I signed over 300
bipartisan pieces of legislation since
becoming president from reauthorizing
the violence against women act the
Electoral count Reform Act the respect
for marriage act that protects the right
to marry the person you love and to my
Republican friends if we could work
together the last Congress there's no
reason we can't work together and find
consensus on important things in this
Congress as well I can think of a few
reasons
I think
folks
New Orleans is formed as I am but I
think the people sent us a clear message
fighting for the sake of fighting power
for the sake of power Conflict for the
sake of conflict gets us nowhere
that's always been my vision of our
country and I know it's many of yours to
restore the soul of this nation to
rebuild the backbone of America
America's middle class and to unite the
country
we've been sent here to finish the job
in my view
for decades the middle class has been
hollowed out in more than and not know
one Administration but for a long time
too many good pain manufacturing jobs
move overseas factories closed down once
thriving cities and towns that many of
you represent became Shadows of what
they used to be
along the way something else we lost
Pride our sense of self-worth
I ran for president to fundamentally
change things to make sure our economy
works for everyone so we can all feel
that pride in what we do
to build an economy from the bottom up
in the middle out
not from the top down because when the
middle class does well the poor have a
ladder up and the wealthy still do very
well we all do well
karthi doesn't like it
there's Bernie
I know a lot of you always kidding me
for always quoting my dad but my dad
used to say Joey and jobs a bottle a lot
more than a paycheck you really would
say this it's about a lot more than a
paycheck it's about your dignity it's
about respect it's about being able to
look your kid in the eye and say honey
it's going to be okay and mean it
folks
so let's look at the results
we're not finished yet by any stretch of
the imagination but unemployment rate is
at 3.4 percent of 50-year low that's
true
it's just a fact and imagine being these
Republicans and not clapping for that
what all of a sudden you can't trust
that Mitt Romney has the testicular
fortitude to get up and clap we've
already created your help eight hundred
thousand good paying manufacturing jobs
the fastest growth in 40 years
thank you
and where is it written
where is it written that America can't
lead the world in manufacturing I don't
know where that's written
for too many decades we imported
projects and exported jobs
now thanks to what you've all done we're
exporting American products and creating
American jobs
folks inflation
inflation has been a global problem
because the pandemic disrupted our
supply chains and Putin's unfair and
brutal war in Ukraine disrupted energy
supplies as well as Food Supplies
blocking all that grain in Ukraine
but we're a better position than any
country on Earth right now but we have
more to do but here at home inflation is
coming down here at home gas prices are
down a dollar fifty from their Peak food
inflation is coming down not fast enough
but coming down inflation has fallen
every month for the last six months or
take-home pay has gone up all true
additionally over the last two years a
record 10 million Americans apply to
start new businesses 10 million
and by the way
every time someone starts a small
business is an act of Hope
and Madam vice president I want to thank
you for leading that effort to ensure
the small businesses have access to
Capital
and the historic laws reenact it that
are going to just come into being
standing here this year
I shared with you a story
of American genius and possibilities
semiconductors
small computer chips the size of a
fingerprint that power everything from
cell phones to automobiles that's JP
right JD Mandel in America let's get
that straight they were invented in
America
can we used to make 40 percent of the
world's chips
in the last several decades we lost our
Edge we're down only producing 10
percent
we all saw what happened during the
pandemic when chip factories shut down
overseas today's automobiles need 3 000
chips each of those automobiles
but American automobiles couldn't make
enough cars because there weren't enough
chips
car prices went up people got laid off
so did everything from refrigerators to
cell phones we can never let that happen
again that's why
that's why we came together to pass the
bipartisan chips and science Act
there you go
these people
I know I've been criticized for saying
this but I'm not changing my view
we're going to make sure the supply
chain for America begins in America the
supply chain begins in America
we've already created
you've already created
800 000 new manufacturing jobs without
this law before the law get kicks in
with this new law we're going to create
hundreds of thousands of new jobs across
the country I mean all across the
country throughout not just the coast
but through the middle of the country as
well
that's going to come from companies that
have announced more than 300 billion
dollars in investment in American
manufacturing over the next few years
outside of Columbus Ohio Intel is
building semiconductor factories on a
thousand acres literally a Field of
Dreams it's going to create ten thousand
jobs that one investment
seven thousand construction jobs
three thousand jobs in those factories
once they're finished they call them
factors
jobs paying an average of a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars a year and many
do not require a college degree
McCarthy's really struggling here not to
clap oh my goodness look at Ted Cruz
work together these jobs where people
don't have to leave home to search for
opportunity
it's just getting started
think about the new homes the small
businesses the big the medium-sized
businesses so much more that's going to
be needed to support those 3000 those 3
000 permanent jobs
and the factories that are going to be
built
talk to Mayors and governors Democrats
and Republicans and they'll tell you
what this means for their communities
we're seeing these Field of Dreams
transform to the heartland
but to maintain the strongest economy in
the world we need the best
infrastructure in the world
folks
as you all know
there's Pete
we used to be number one in the world in
infrastructure
we've sunk to 13th in the world the
United States of America
13th in the world and infrastructure
modern infrastructure
but now we're coming back because we
came together and passed the bipartisan
infrastructure law the largest
investment infrastructure since
President Eisenhower's interstate
highway system
wow
already we've funded over 20 000
projects including major airports from
Boston to Atlanta to Portland projects
are going to put thousands of people to
work rebuilding our highways our bridges
our railroads our tunnels ports airports
clean water high-speed internet all
across America Urban rural tribal and
folks were just getting started we're
just getting started
and I mean you sincerely
I want to thank my Republican friends
who voted for the law
and my Republican friends who voted
against it as well
but I'm still I I still get asked to
fund the projects in those districts as
well but don't worry
I promised I'd be a president for all
Americans we'll fund these projects and
I'll see you at the groundbreaking
look oh boy
this law Biden started slow but he's
picking up the pace here I'm liking it i
will further unite all of America
projects like Brent spent bridge in
Kentucky over the Ohio River
built 60 years ago badly needed repairs
one of the nation's most congested
Freight routes carrying two billion
dollars worth of freight every single
day across the Ohio River and folks hey
has Joe manchin clapped at anything so
far you're gonna get it done
yeah I went there last month with
Democrats and Republicans and from both
states to deliver a commitment of 1.6
billion dollars for this project
while I was there
I met a young woman named Sarah who's
here tonight I don't know where Sarah is
the chef in the Box I don't know Sarah
how are you
well Sarah for 30 years
for 30 years
I learned she told me she'd been a proud
member of the Iron Workers Local 44
known as
known as the Cowboys in the sky
the folks who built
Bill Cincinnati skyline Sarah said she
can't wait to be 10 stories above the
Ohio River Building that new bridge God
bless her
that's pride and that's her also
building we're building back Pride look
we're also replacing poisonous lead
pipes that go into 10 million homes in
America
000 school and Child Care Centers so
every child in America
every child American drink the water
instead of having permanent damage to
their brain
look
seems better yeah we're making sure
should be a priority
for making sure
that every community
every community in America has access to
Affordable high-speed internet no parent
should have to drive by McDonald's
parking lot to help for do their
farmwork online or their kids which many
thousands were doing across the country
and when we do these projects
and again I get criticize this but I
make no excuses for it we're going to
buy American we're going to buy America
folks
and it's totally is totally consistent
with International Trade rules
why America has been the law since 1933
but for too long past administration is
Democrat and Republican have not anymore
tonight I'm announcing new standards
require all construction materials used
in Federal National infrastructure
projects to be made in America
why didn't Trump do that if Trump's so
tough on China
I mean it
Lumber
glass drywall fiber optic cable and I
might watch American roads Bridges and
American highways are going to be made
with American Products as well folks
my economic plan is about investing in
places and people that have been
forgotten
so many of you listen to me tonight
I know you feel it
so many of you felt like you've just
simply been forgotten
amid the economic upheaval of the past
four decades
too many people have been left behind
and treated like they're invisible
maybe that's you watching from home
remember the jobs that went away you
remember them don't you
Folks at home remember them
you wonder whether the path even exists
anymore for your children to get ahead
without having to move away
well that's why I get that
that's why we're building an economy
where no one's left behind
jobs are coming back pride is coming
back
because choices we made in the last
several years
you know
this is my view of blue collar blueprint
to rebuild America make a real
difference in your lives at home for
example
too many of you
lay in bed at night like my dad did
staring at the ceiling wondering what
God names happens if your spouse gets
cancer
or your child gets deadly ill
or something happens to you
what are you going to getting money to
pay for those medical bills or you're
going to have to sell the house or try
to get a second mortgage on it I get it
I get it
with the inflation reduction act that I
signed into law
we're taking on powerful interest to
bring health care costs down
so you can sleep better at night
with more security
you know we pay more for prescription
drugs than any nation in the world let
me say it again we pay more for
prescription drugs than any major Nation
on Earth
for example
one in 10 Americans has diabetes
many of you in this chamber do and then
the audience
but every day Millions need insulin to
control their diabetes
so they can literally stay alive
insulin's been around for over a hundred
years
the guy who invented didn't even patent
him because he wanted to be available
for everyone
it costs the drug companies roughly
ten dollars a vial to make that insulin
package it and all you may get up to
thirteen dollars this is a big
announcement big Pharma has been
unfairly charging people hundreds of
dollars four to five hundred dollars a
month
making record profits not anymore
not anymore
so many so many things that we did are
only now coming to fruition
we said we were doing this and we said
we passed the law to do it but people
didn't know because the law didn't take
effect until January 1 of this year
we capped the cost of insulin at 35 a
month for seniors on Medicare
that's a big deal people are just
finding out
I'm sure you're getting the same calls
I'm getting
look there are millions of other
Americans
who do not or are not on Medicare
including two hundred thousand young
people with type 1 diabetes in these
needless insulin to stay alive
let's finish the job this time let's cap
the cost events for everybody at 35
dollars
major announcement folks
folks
big Farmer's still going to do very well
I promise you all I promise you they're
going to do very well
this loss of this law someone just
yelling morning going in effect did you
guys hear that 2025
cost out-of-pocket drug costs for
seniors on Medicare at a maximum of two
thousand dollars a year you don't have
to pay more than two thousand dollars no
matter how much your drug costs are
because you know why you all know it
many of you like many of my family have
cancer
you know the drugs can range from 10 11
14 15
000 for the Cancer drugs
if drug prices rise faster than
inflation drug companies are going to
have to pay Medicare back the difference
or finally
and finally giving Medicare the power to
negotiate drug prices
bringing down
it cuts the federal deficit by billions
of dollars
by hundreds of billions of dollars
because these prescription drugs are
drugs purchased by Medicare to make keep
their commitment to the seniors
well guess what
instead of paying four or five hundred
bucks a month you're paying 15. that's a
lot of savings for the federal
government
and by the way why wouldn't we want that
now some members here are threatening
and I know it's not an official party
position so I'm not I'm going to
exaggerate
but certainly to repeal the inflation
reduction Act
as my coach
that's okay that's fair
as my football coach used to say lots of
luck in your senior year
make no mistake
if you try anything to raise the cost of
Brazilian jobs I will veto it
look nicely done sir
please the same the more Americans have
health insurance now than ever in
history a record 16 million people are
enrolled in the Affordable Care Act and
thanks
thanks for the law I signed last year
saving millions of saving 800 a year on
their premiums by the way that law was
written
and the benefit expires in 2025
so my plea to some of you at least in
this audience let's finish the job and
make these savings permanent
expand coverage on Medicaid Obama
Kirsten doesn't like it
look
the inflation reduction Act is also the
most significant investment ever in
climate change
ever
Lauren
you took traded American jobs leading
the world to a clean energy future I
visited the devastating aftermath of
record floods droughts storms and
wildfires from Arizona New Mexico to all
the way up to the Canadian border
more Timber has been burned as I've
observed from helicopters than the
entire state of Missouri
and we don't have global warming not a
problem
in addition to emergency recovery from
Puerto Rico to Florida to Idaho we're
rebuilding for the long term
new electric grids that are able to
weather major storms and not prevent
those forest fires roads and Water
Systems withstand the next big flood
clean energy to cut pollution and create
jobs and communities often left behind
we're going to build 500 000 electric
vehicle charging stations installed
that'll cross the country by tens of
thousands of IBEW that I love I am big
big on that
we're helping families save more than a
thousand dollars a year with tax credits
to purchase electric vehicles and
efficient an efficient appliances energy
efficient appliances I will soon be
announcing that I am getting an
induction cooktop and getting rid of my
gas stove folks let's face reality
the climate creation doesn't care if
you're in a red or blue state
it's an existential threat
we have an obligation not to ourselves
but our children or grandchildren to
confront it
I'm proud of how the how America at last
is stepping up to the challenge
we're still going to need oil and gas
for a while
but guess what no we do
imagine clapping so much more to do
people are morons we got to finish the
job
we pay for these investments in our
future by finally making the wealthiest
and biggest corporations begin to pay
their fair share
they're not fans of that
not fans of that
well gone with capitalist I'm a
capitalist but pay your fair share
I think a lot of you at home a lot of
you at home agree with me and many
people that you know
the tax system is not fair it is not
fair
the idea give me a break that in 2020.
55 of the largest corporations in
America the fortune 500. made 40 billion
dollars in profits and paid zero in
federal taxes
zero
both simply not fair
but now because of the law I signed
billion dollar companies have to pay a
minimum of 15 God loved them
what a tragedy
clear I said at the very beginning
under my plans as long as I'm president
nobody earning less than four hundred
thousand dollars will pay an additional
penny in taxes nobody not one penny
well let's finish the job there's more
to do here we go
we have to reward work not just wealth
pass my proposal for the billionaire
minimum tax there it is you know there's
a thousand billionaires in America it's
up from about 600 in the beginning
return
no billionaire should be paying a lower
tax rate than the school teacher or
firefighter
I mean it McCarthy won't clap for that
McCarthy's like no the school teacher
should be paying a higher tax rate than
the billionaire
I know you are enthusiastic about that
but think about it
think about it
have you noticed Big Oil just reported
his profits record profits
last year they made
200 billion dollars in the midst of a
global energy crisis
I think it's outrageous
why they invested too little people
they're yelling increased domestic
production
and when I talked to a couple of them
they say we're afraid you're going to
shut down all the oil wells and all the
uh oil refineries anyway so why should
we invest in them look at McCarthy I
said we're going to need oil for at
least another decade
and that's going to exceed
at least
we're gonna need it
production
if they had in fact invested in the
production to keep gas prices down
instead they used the record profits to
buy back their own stock
rewarding the CEOs and shareholders
corporations ought to do the right thing
that's why I propose we quadruple the
tax on corporate stock BuyBacks and
encourage long long-term Investments
McCarthy's a no
they'll still make considerable profit
let's finish the job and close the
loopholes that allow very wealthy to
avoid paying their taxes instead of
cutting the number of orders for wealthy
taxpayers I just signed a law to reduce
the deficit by 114 billion dollars by
cracking down on Wealthy tax sheets
that's been fiscally responsible
in the last two years
Mansion seems like he doesn't even know
where he is why more than
1.7 trillion dollars
the largest deficit reduction in
American history
under the previous administration the
American deficit went up four years in a
row
because those record deficits no
president added more than the national
debt
in 94 years than my predecessor
nearly 25 percent of the entire national
debt that took over 200 years to
accumulate was added by just one
Administration alone the last one
better facts check it out
there's the screaming how did Congress
respond to that debt
they did the right thing they left to
the debt ceiling three times without
preconditions or crisis
they paid American bills to prevent an
economic disaster in the country so
tonight I'm asking the Congress to
follow suit there it is let's commit
here tonight to the full phasing credit
of the United States of America will
never ever be questioned
so my many some of my Republican friends
want to take the economy hostage I get
it unless I agree to their economic
plans
all of you at home should know what
those plans are
instead of making the wealthy pay their
fair share some Republicans some
Republicans want Medicare and Social
Security Sunset I'm not saying it's a
majority
[Applause]
let me give you anybody who doubts it
Rick Scott wanted that in the office
I'll give you a copy oh no oh God
disgusting Marjorie Taylor green that
means Congress doesn't vote
well I'm glad to see you now I tell you
I enjoy conversion
remover amazing
if Congress doesn't keep the programs
the way they are they'd go away other
Republicans say I'm not saying it's a
majority of you I don't even think it's
even a significant
vile woman but it's being proposed by
individuals what is she wearing by the
way what is this politely not naming
them but it's being proposed by somebody
just look at desperation for attention
there in every way huh
folks
the idea is
that we're not going to be we're not
going to be moved in is McCarthy
shushing green did you did you guys see
that on
folks
so folks
as we all apparently agree
Social Security Medicare is also off the
books now right
all right
there it is I mean listen
they all booed when he said you guys are
open to cutting it so I guess it
shouldn't ever come up again
Social Security Medicare or Lifeline for
millions of seniors Americans have to
pay into them from the very first
paycheck they started so tonight let's
all agree and apparently are let's stand
up for seniors
stand up and show them
will not cut Social Security we will not
cut Medicare
those benefits belong to the American
people they earned it and if anyone
tries to cut Social Security which
apparently no one's going to do
they said it and if anyone tries it's
got Medicare I'll stop them I'll veto it
and look I'm not going to allow them to
take away be taken away not today not
tomorrow not ever but apparently it's
not going to be a problem right next
month
when I offer my fiscal plan I ask my
Republican friends to lay down their
plan as well
I really mean it let's sit down together
and discuss our mutual plans together
let's do that
there you go
I can tell you
the plan I'm going to show is going to
cut the deficit by another two trillion
dollars
and I won't cut a single bit of Medicare
or self-security in fact we're going to
extend the Medicare trust fund at least
two decades they'll be against that how
do we make keep it solvent right
well we'll not raise tax anyone making
under 400 Grand but
will pay for it the way we talked about
by making sure that the wealthy and big
corporations pay their fair share look
look here's the deal
they aren't just taking advantage of the
tax code they're taking advantage you
the American Consumer here's my message
to all of you out there I have your back
we're already preventing Americans and
receiving surprise medical bills
stopping one billion dollar surprise
bills per month so far
we're protecting
[Applause]
Asian homes that commit fraud endanger
patient safety prescribe drugs that are
not needed millions of Americans can now
save thousands of dollars because they
can finally get a hearing aid over the
counter without a prescription
look wow
capitalism
without competition is not capitalism
it's extortion
is exploitation
last year I cracked down with the help
of many of you on foreign shipping
companies that were making you pay
higher prices for every good coming in
the country I signed a bipartisan Bill a
cut shipping costs by 90 percent helping
American farmers businessmen and
consumers let's finish the job
pass the bipartisan legislation of
strength and strengthen and Trust
enforcement and forbid and prevent big
online platforms giving their own
products an unfair advantage
thank you
my Administration has also taking on
junk fees those hidden surcharges too
many companies use to make you pay more
for example we're making Airlines show
you the full ticket price up front
refund your money if your flight is
canceled or delayed we reduce
exorbitant Bank overdrafts by Saving
consumers more than one billion dollars
a year
for cutting credit card late fees by 75
percent from thirty dollars to eight
dollars
look
junk fees
may not matter to the very wealthy but
they matter to most other folks in homes
like the one I grew up in like many of
you did they add up to hundreds of
dollars a month
they make it harder for you to pay your
bills and afford that family trip
I know how unfair it feels when a
company overcharges you and gets away
with it not anymore
we've written a bill to stop it all it's
called the junk fee prevention Act
we're going to ban surprise Resort fees
that hotels charge on your bill should
have seen the ones tacked onto my bill
in Florida last week even resorts
we the idea
that cable internet and cell phone
companies can charge you 200 or more if
you decide to switch another provider
true give me a break
we can stop service fees on tickets to
concerts and sporting events and make
companies as close all the fees up front
and will prohibit Airlines from charging
50 round trip for family just to be able
to sit together
these are bad enough
Airlines can't treat your child like a
piece of baggage
America's
because they're being played for suckers
so pass
the jump free prevention act so
companies stop ripping us off
for too long
workers have been getting stiffed but
not anymore
we're getting we're beginning to restore
the Dignity of work for example
I I should have known this but I didn't
until two years ago
30 million workers have to sign
non-compete agreements
with the jobs they take 30 million
so a cashier
at a burger place can't walk across town
and take the same job at another burger
place and make a few bucks more
just change
but they just changed it because we
exposed it
that was part of the deal guys look it
up
but not anymore
we're Banning those agreements so
companies have to compete for workers
and pay them what they're worth
and I must tell you
this is bound to get a response from my
friends on my left but the right
I'm so sick and tired of companies
breaking the law by preventing workers
from organizing
it's the pro Act
[Applause]
let's guarantee all workers have a
living wage
let's make sure working parents can
afford to raise a family with sick days
Paid Family Medical Leave affordable
child care
that's going to enable millions of more
people to go and stay at work and let's
restore the full child tax credit
which gave tens of millions of parents
some breathing room and cut child
poverty in half to the lowest level in
history and by the way when we do all
these things we increase productivity we
increase economic growth so let's finish
the job
and get more families access to
affordable quality housing let's get
seniors who want to stay in their homes
the care they need to do so
let's get more breathing room to
millions of family caregivers looking
after their loved ones
past my plan so we get seniors and
people with disabilities the home care
and services they need
and support
the workers who are doing God's work
they're against all the reports
plans are fully paid for and we can
afford to do them
restoring the Dignity of work means
making education an affordable ticket to
the middle class
you know when we made public education
12 years of it Universal in the last
century
we made the best educated best paid we
became the best educated best paid
nation in the world
the rest was caught up it's caught up
Jill my wife who teaches full time has
an expression
I hope I get it right kid
any nation that out educates us is going
to out-compete us Indian Asian out
education can now compete us folks we
all know 12 years of education is not
enough to win the economic competition
of 21st century
you want to have the best educated
Workforce let's finish the job
by providing access to preschool for
three and four years old
studies show that children to go to
preschool are nearly 50 percent more
likely to finish high school and go on
to earn a two or four year degree no
matter their background they came from
let's get Public School teachers a raise
man these Republicans are just against
everything
who's screaming by the way it's
increasing Pell Grants for working in
Middle Class families let's finish the
job
it connects students to career
opportunities starting in high school
provide access to two years of Community
College the best career training in
America in addition to being a pathway
to a four-year degree
let's offer every American a path to a
good career whether they go to college
or not
to folks
folks in the midst of the kova crisis
schools were closed
Biden just turned like eight pages at
once that was weird
let's recognize how far we came in the
fight against the pandemic itself
while the virus is not gone
thanks to resilience of the American
people and the Ingenuity of Medicine
we've broken the cover grip on us
covered deaths are down by 90 percent
we've saved millions of lives and opened
up
our country we open our country back up
and soon we'll end the public health
emergency but
that's called a public health emergency
but we'll remember the toll and pain is
never going to go away
more than a million Americans lost their
lives of covert a million
families grieving
children an orphaned
Empty Chairs the dining room table
constantly reminding you
that she used to sit there
remembering them
we remain vigilant
we still need to monitor dozens of
variants and support new vaccines and
treatments
so Congress needs to fund these efforts
and keep America safe
and as we emerge from this crisis
stronger
we're also got to double down on
Prosecuting criminals who stole relief
money meant to keep workers in small
businesses
before I came to office you remember
during that campaign the big issue was
about inspector generals
who would protect taxpayers dollars from
her sideline
they were fired
many people said we don't need them
and fraud became rampant
last year I told you the Watchdogs are
back
since then since then we've covered
billions of taxpayers dollars now let's
triple the anti-fraud strike force going
after these criminals double the statute
of limitations on these crimes and crack
down on identity fraud by criminal
syndicates stealing billions of dollars
billions of dollars from the American
people
finally something McCarthy
now for every dollar we put in the
fighting fraud the tax service get back
at least 10 times as much it matters it
matters
look
cover left his scars
like to spike in violent crime in 2020.
the first year of the pandemic
we have an obligation to make sure all
people are safe
Public Safety depends on public trust as
all of us know
but too often that trust is violated
join us tonight are the parents
Tyree Nichols
welcome
pressing situation
I had to bury Tyree last week
as many of you personally know there's
no word to describe the heartache or
brief of losing a child
but imagine
if you lost that child at the hands of
the law
imagine
having to worry whether your son or
daughter came home from walking down the
street
playing in the park or just driving a
car
most of us in here
have never had to have the talk
the talk the brown and black parents
have had to have with their children Bo
Hunter Ashley my children
I never had to have a talk with them
I never had to tell them if a police
officer pulls you over
turn your interior lights on right away
don't reach for your license
keep your hands on the steering wheel
imagine having to worry like that every
single time
your kid got in a car
here's what tyree's mother shared with
me when I spoke to her
when I asked her how she finds the
courage to carry on and speak out
the faith of God she said her son was
quote a beautiful soul
and something good will come of this
imagine how much courage and carry that
takes
it's up to us to all of us we all want
the same thing
neighborhoods free of violence
law enforcement law enforcement earns
the community's trust
just as every cop when they pin on that
badge in the morning has a right to be
able to go home at night
so does everybody else out there
our children
have a right to come home safely
equal protection under the law as a
covenant we have with each other in
America
we know
police officers put their lives on the
line every single night and day
and we know we ask them in many cases to
do too much to be councilman social
workers psychologists responding to drug
overdoses mental health crises and so
much more
in one sense we asked much too much of
them
I know most cops and their families are
good decent honorable people the vast
majority
and they risk their lives every time
they put that shield on
but what happened to Tyree in Memphis
happens too often
we have to do better
give law enforcement the real training
they need
hold them to higher standards
help them succeed in keeping us safe
we also need more first respondents and
professionals to address the growing
mental health substance abuse challenges
more resources reduce violent crime and
gun crimes
more Community Intervention Program
more Investments housing education and
job training
all this
can help prevent violence in the first
place
when police officers
or police departments violate the public
Trust
they must be held accountable
with the support
to the support
of the families of victims
civil rights groups and law enforcement
I signed an executive order for all
federal officers
Banning chokeholds restricting no knock
warrants another key elements of the
George Floyd Act
let's commit ourselves to make the words
of Tyler's mom true
something good must come from this
something good
did he say Tyler
and all of us
all of us
folks it's difficult but it's simple all
of us in the chain in this chamber we
need to rise to this moment
can't turn away
let's do what we know in our hearts
we need to do
let's come together to finish the job on
police reform
do something do something
that was The Plea of parents who lost
their children Uvalde I met with every
one of them
do something about gun violence
thank God
thank God we did
passing the most sweeping gun safety law
in three decades
that includes things like
that the majority of responsible gun
owners already support
enhanced background checks for 18 to 21
years old red flag laws keeping guns out
of the hands of people are a danger to
themselves and others
but we know our work is not done
join us tonight is Brandon say a 26 year
old hero Brandon put his college dreams
on hold to beat his mom's side his mom's
side when she was dying from cancer
Brandon
Brandon now works at the dance studio
started by his grandparents and two
weeks ago
there are no Lunar New Year celebrations
you heard the studio door close you saw
a man standing there pointing
semi-automatic pistol at him
he thought he was going to die
but he thought about the people inside
in that instant he found the courage to
act and wrestle the semi-automatic
pistol away from the gunman who had
already killed 11 people in another
Dance Studio
11.
he saved lives
it's time we do the same band assault
weapons now ban them now
once and for all
I love the fight to do that in 1994.
I mean in 10 years that ban was law mass
shootings went down after we let it
expire in the Republican Administration
mass shootings tripled let's finish the
job and ban these assault weapons
and let's also come together on
immigration
make it a bipartisan issue once again
we know we now have a record number of
personnel working to secure the Border
arresting eight thousand human Smugglers
seizing over 23 thousand pounds of
fentanyl in just the last several months
we've launched a new border plan last
month
unlawful migration from Cuba Haiti
Nicaragua and Venezuela has come down 97
as a consequence of that
but American Border problems won't be
fixed until Congress Acts if we don't
pass my comprehensive immigration reform
at least past my plan to provide the
equipment and officers to secure the
Border
and a pathway to citizenship for
dreamers those on temporary status Farm
Workers essential workers
here in the people's house
it's our duty to protect all the
people's rights and freedoms
Congress must restore the right and the
who's yelling now
Congress must restore the right these
people I was taken away
in Roe v Wade and protect Roe v Wade
give everyone a cost away
the vice president and I are doing
everything
exact access to reproductive health care
and Safeguard patient safety
but already more than a dozen states are
enforcing extreme abortion bans make no
mistake about it Congress passes a
national ban I will veto it
but let's also
it's also
quality act to ensure LPG lgbtq
Americans especially transgender young
people can live with safety and dignity
our strength
no clapping there from Republicans for
safety and dignity the example
but the power
to remember the war
I spoke in this chamber one year ago
just days after Vladimir Putin unleashes
brutal attack against Ukraine
a murderous assault evoking images of
death and destruction Europe suffered in
World War II
Putin's Invasion has been a test
for the ages
test for America the test for the world
would we stand for the most basic of
principles
who we stand for sovereignty we stand
for the right of people to live free of
tyranny
will we stand for the defense of
democracy
for such defense matters to us because
it keeps peace and prevents Open Season
and would be aggressive and threatens
our prosperity
one year later
we know the answer yes we would and we
did we did
and together
we did what America always does at our
best we LED
we United NATO
we built a global coalition
we stood against Putin's aggression
we stood with Ukrainian people to deny
we're once again joined by ukrainians
ambassador to the United States she
represents not her and just our nation
but the courage of her People ambassador
as our ambassador is here United we're
in uniting our support of your country
would you stand so we can all take a
look at you
because we're going to stand with you
as long as it takes
our nation's working for more freedom
more dignity more more peace not just in
Europe but everywhere
before I came to office the story was
about how the People's Republic of China
was increasing its power
and America was failing in the world
not anymore
we made clear and I made my personal
conversation which have been many with
President XI that we seek competition
not conflict
but I will make no apologies
that we're investing and to make America
stronger investing in American
innovation and industries will Define
the future that China intends to be
dominated
investing in our alliances and working
with our allies to protect advanced
technology McCarthy shushing what
sounded like green there once again just
an embarrassment to her self and her
party to deter aggression today we're
the strongest position in decades to
compete with China or anyone else in the
world anywhere else in the world
when I'm committed
I'm committed to work with China where
we can advance American interest and
benefit the world but make no mistake
about it
as we made clear last week if China
threatens our sovereignty we will act to
protect our country and we did
the balloon
look
let's be clear when in the competition
should you're nine all of us
we Face serious challenges across the
world
but in the past two years democracies
have become stronger and not weaker
autocracy has grown weaker not stronger
name me a world leader
who changed places with Xi Jinping name
me one
name me one
America's rallying the world to meet
those challenges from climate to Global
Health to food insecurity to terrorism
to territorial aggression
allies are stepping up spending more and
doing more
look
the bridges were forming between
partners in the Pacific and those in the
Atlantic
and those who bet against America are
learning how wrong they are it's never
ever been a good bet to bet against
America never
McCarthy sort of is going with that
wow
when I came to office most assured the
bipartisanship assumed was impossible
but never believed it that's why a year
ago I offered a Unity agenda to the
nation as I stood here we made real
progress together
we passed the law and make it easy for
doctors to prescribe effective
treatments for opioid addiction
we passed
for gun safety law making historic
investments in mental health
we launched the arpa H drive for
breakthrough in the fights against
cancer Alzheimer's and diabetes and so
much more
we passed that Heath Robinson packed act
named after the late Iraq war veteran
whose story about exposure to toxic burn
kids I shared here last year
I understand something about those burn
pits but there's so much more to do
we can do it together
joining us tonight is a father named
Doug
from Newton New Hampshire
he wrote Jill my wife a letter and me as
well
about his courageous daughter Courtney
a contagious laugh
his sister's best friend her sister's
best friend
he shared the story all too familiar to
millions of Americans and many of you in
the audience
Courtney discovered pills in high school
it spiraled into addiction
and eventually death from a fentanyl
overdose
she was just 20 years old
described in the last eight years
without her Doug said
there's no worse pain
if their families turned pain to purpose
working to end the stigma and change
laws
he told us he wants to start a journey
toward American Recovery
Doug or with you
fentanyl is killing more than 70
thousand Americans a year
[Applause]
your God we're doing
people are yelling it's your fault
so let's launch a major surge to stop
fentanyl production in the sale and
trafficking with more drug detection
machines it's hard to imagine more
disgusting and self-debasing people
working with Currys like FedEx to
inspect more packages for drugs
strong penalties to crack down on
fentanyl trafficking
second let's do more mental health
especially for our children
when millions of young people are
struggling with bullying violence trauma
we're them greater access to Mental
Health Care at their schools
we must finally hold social media
companies accountable for experimenting
or doing running children for profit
there's time to pass bipartisan
reservation to stop big Tech from
collecting personal data on our kids and
teenagers online
faded targeted advertising their
children and impose stricter limits on
the personal data that companies collect
on all of this
third
let's do more to keep this nation's ones
truly sacred obligation
to equip those we send into Harm's Way
and care for them and their families
when they come home
job training job placement for veterans
and their spouses as they come to return
to civilian life helping veterans afford
the rent because no one should be
homeless in America especially someone
who served the country
basic stuff
and we can't do it
Dennis mcducken Dennis McDonough is here
of the VA
we had our first real discussion when I
asked him to take the job I'm glad he
did
we were losing up to 25 veterans a day
on suicide
now we're losing 17 today to the silent
scourge of suicide 17 veterans a day
are committing suicide
more than all the people being killed in
the wars
folks VA is doing everything it can
including expanding mental health
screening
proven programs of recruits veterans to
help other veterans understand what
they're going through
get them the help they need
we got to do more
and fourth
last year Jill and I reignited the
cancer moonshot
that I was able to start with President
Obama asked me to lead our
Administration on this issue
our goal is to cut the cancer death
rates
at least by 50 in the next 25 years
turn more cancer from death sentences to
treatable diseases
provide more support for patients and
their families
it's personal to so many of us so many
of us in this audience
joining us
are Morris and Candice
an Irishman and a daughter of immigrants
from Panama
they met and fell in love in New York
City and got married in the same Chapel
Jill and I got married in New York City
Kindred Spirits he wrote us a letter
about his little daughter Ava
and I saw her just before I came over
she was just a year old when she was
diagnosed with rare kidney disease
cancer
after 26 blood transfusions
11 rounds of radiation eight rounds of
quinoa chemo
one kidney removed
giving a five percent survival rate
he wrote how in the darkest moments he
thought if she goes I can't stay
many of you been through that as well
Jillian I understand that like so many
of you
he read Jill's book describing our
family's cancer Journey
and how we try to steal moments of joy
where we could with Bo
for them that glimmer of Joy was the
half smile
of their baby girl
it meant everything to them
they never gave up hope
little Ava never gave up hope
she turns four next month
[Applause]
give me the odds is on our way to being
cured of cancer
and she's watching from the White House
tonight if she's not asleep already
for the lives we can save
for the lives we can say in the lives
we've lost
let this be a truly American moment that
rallies the country in the world
together
prove that we can still do big things
20 years ago under the leadership of
President Bush
and countless Advocates and champions he
undertook a bipartisan effort through
pepfar to transform the global fight
against HIV AIDS it's been a huge
success he thought big he thought large
he moved
I believe we can do the same thing with
cancer
let's end cancer as we know it
cure some cancers
once and for all
folks
there's one reason why we've been able
to do all of these things
our democracy itself
it's the most fundamental thing of all
democracy everything's possible
without it nothing is
the last few years our democracy has
been threatened and attacked put at risk
put to the test In This Very Room on
January the 6th and then just a few
months ago
a non-hedged big lie
a sale and unleash a political violence
the home of the then Speaker of the
House of Representatives
using the very same language the
insurrectionists used as they stalk
these Halls Enchanted on January 6th
here tonight in this chamber is a man
who Bears the scars of that brutal
attack
but it's as tough and as strong as
resilient as they get my friend Paul
Pelosi Paul Stanley
good to see him there
it's such a heinous act should have
never happened
we must all speak out
there's no place for political violence
in America we have to protect the right
to vote not suppress the fat fundamental
right honor the results of our elections
not subvert the will of people we have
to uphold the rule of law and restore
trusting our institutions of democracy
and we must give hate and extremism in
any form no Safe Harbor
how on Earth does McCarthy get away with
not clapping oh now now he's reluctantly
started the club by my God
[Applause]
it's the moment where they haven't been
to protect our democracy defend it stand
up for it
and this is our moment
my fellow Americans
we meet tonight at an inflection point
one of those moments
than only a few Generations ever face
with the direction
we now take is going to decide the
course of this nation for decades to
come
we're not bystanders of History
we're not powerless before the forces
that confront us
it's within our power of We the People
we're facing the test of our time
we have to be the nation we've always
been at our best optimistic hopeful
forward-looking a nation of Embraces
light over dark
hope over fear Unity stability over
chaos
we have to see each other not as enemies
but as fellow Americans
we're good people the only nation in the
world built on an idea the only one
other nations
are defined by geography ethnicity
[Applause]
but we're the only nation based on an
idea
that all of us
every one of us is created equal in the
image of God
a nation that stands as a beacon of the
world
a nation
and a new age of possibilities
so I've come to
fulfill my constitutional obligation to
report in the state of the union and
here's a reminder my report
because the soul of this nation is
strong
because the backboken backbone of this
nation is strong because the people of
this nation are strong the state of the
union is strong
thank you
I'm not new to this place I stand you
tonight having served as long as about
any one of you who've ever served here
but I've never been more optimistic
about our future about the future
America just to remember who we are
we're the United States of America and
there's nothing nothing beyond our
capacity if we do it together God bless
you all may God protect our truth there
it is thank you
foreign
well
truly hard to remember a more disgusting
performance during a State of the Union
Address by a house speaker
then Kevin McCarthy's performance
tonight just vile but let's not let him
overshadow what in some total
was a very good speech a number of
policy proposals outlined
an energy that matched
the circumstances of the country at this
time
and making very clear in a number of
areas with undeniable facts which
Republicans will say they don't matter
anymore none of those numbers matter
anymore
uh it's really hard to make a
mathematical case
that we have a disastrous economy right
now as Republicans want to say and of
course the uh unemployment rate is only
one part of it but you look at a
Workforce participation wages of
inflation coming down stock market over
the last several months it is very
difficult to make any strong
mathematical case that the economy is
not currently doing well now the
recession uh fear-mongering continues of
course eventually there's going to be a
recession that's the way that our system
works unless something changes
um but these are folks and Republicans
who have completely abandoned even
pretending to care about policy
and who really have no bottom really
have no bottom whatsoever
there are people saying David can you
just remind us of how other speeches
from from former people could have gone
no more the drop boxes
we have to keep our country gay and the
combat infant tripping and God bless
the United States Americans of all walks
of life rose up
a rhino named Mitt Romney
virtue cycling okay I've had more
investigations than Jesse James Billy
the could okay all right anyway so we
get we could sort of leave it there I
think yeah infant trooping gets me every
time and the combat infant tripping yeah
uh all right folks well listen we saw it
I'm going to uh take time to really
deeply think about what was presented
tonight as far as policy is concerned
and we will have an analysis tomorrow
and I would like to figure out who are
the people
who yelled out disgustingly certainly
Gates
Marjorie Trader green and Lauren bobert
we distinctly heard and saw to some
degree
um have I seen the Hassan AI Clips no
but if people make some David pakman AI
Clips I would love to review them and
look at them very very closely on the
show
all right everybody thank you for
joining me we will have a whole thing
for you tomorrow make sure you're
subscribed everywhere I can't thank you
enough for joining me tonight
and we will see everybody tomorrow thank
you very much